jetzt ist denn die ruhe bei ihr die
mutter und der ich möchte unter zug und
schwester fanny lewald cornetto und
zieht aus machen wir schon immer viele
leute also jetzt das gefühl dass sich
die fonds von detecon und lag damit aber
noch andere verordnungen das natürlich
liebevoll
ich hoffe dass das jetzt wäre klarheit
muss aber gut das ist tom hooper
aufgewachsen im luzernischen meken ruhig
erlebt er als ausländer mechanischen
tropenwald was für den hier her und wie
kann er andere überzeugen dass sein weg
der richtige ist
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
dann ist dieses lied kindheit vor zwei
jahren verließ die jamaikanerin ihr
elternhaus um zu tun in den ausgedehnten
boost westmore land zu ziehen
hier gibt es keinen strom keine
waschmaschine
sie ist 20 50 ein äußerlich ungleiches
liebespaar aber verbündet durch dieselbe
ideologie ich bin eine sehr
begeisterungsfähige person mich
interessiert alles was natur betrifft
und ich liebe sie sehr
deshalb bin ich hier um zu helfen ich
habe in meiner entscheidung gezweifelt
und werde es auch nie tun
vom himmel und ich habe gar nominieren
mehrere monate zeit gehabt habe so gut
verstanden also manches ist überraschend
es ist wirklich es verschiedene autos
unterschied und kultur differenzen aber
max und wirklich wichtige sachen gesagt
wie ich mich und das ist schön
auf seinem land geht ein über 100
früchte sorten
tom ist selbstversorger allerdings
kennenlernte hat er schon über 20 jahre
lang alleine in dieser feuchtheißen
wildnis verbraucht der luzerner
verzichtet auf fleisch und salz weil das
den körper schade sagte er
seine mahlzeiten wird der mii kräutern
das loch stecken bleibe damit immer die
farbe wie das grün also doch finde ich
am meisten forderte mir und es ist
interessant ist also die meisten man
wirklich gut geeignet und herr zimmer
von denen drei farben noch bis in den
80er jahren verließ der gelernte
zimmermann seinen heimatort merken und
zog nach new york dort arbeitete er als
kellner und verkäufer kokosnuss nach
einem ferienaufenthalt in jamaika anfang
der 90er jahre hat er genug von der
modernen zivilisation und alles ist und
es nur im bett und jean alesi und das
hat dazu geführt dass ich jetzt erlebe
ihr leben ist einfach aber manchmal sind
die einfachsten dinge die besten das
sehen beide so sie wollen ein gesundes
leben führen und befolgen die strengen
regeln eines raus der naturarzt das was
geht er dann inne der doktor was
vermittelte erinnern
er ist einfach irgendwie natürlich am
himmel aber ich fand das völlig also am
besten beschrieben
natürlich kam eine große idee und
dadurch natürlich am boden aber holland
lassen wirklich zu dir ist es gut dass
es wichtig ist auch dass ich verstehe
ihre religion
ja wir sind was mir leicht mich in der
letzten periode von hauptorte steht eine
gesunde natürliche münch verwandelt also
es ist nicht religion zu schmierig als
religion was ich es liebe seines lebens
wie groß ist der einfluss des raster
doktors der ganz in der nähe liegt
um das herauszufinden haben sich mutter
und schwester zu einem besuch angemeldet
elisabeth huber kam schon mehrmals in
diese abgelegene gegend aber dies ist
der erste besuch seit dem tod ihres
mannes vor drei jahren zum schwester
barbara landolt war erst einmal hier
das war von neun jahren da nicht sind
beide zum ersten mal
ja es ist noch nicht ganz fertig trotz
allem überstunden gemacht
[Musik]
das ist nicht nur reform
ihr seht wir bauen hier drei räume wir
möchten hier betten herstellen so dass
drei bis vier leute im selben raum
schlafen können
wir möchten gäste beherbergen die nicht
viel geld haben sie können bei uns
gratis übernachten und dafür im garten
mitarbeiten
[Musik]
durch den verkauf von früchten gemüse
und jungen bäumen verdient sich tom
seinen lebensunterhalt
dank finanziellen zustupf durch seine
eltern gehört dass knopf infekt dauern
große land heute ihm
das ist das was ihr sagt ich habe dass
ich sie lässig wurde
[Musik]
das ist überraschend noch darum dass
sich das kaufhaus hören dass das muss
einfach ein ordner vor der natur als
geschenk ein freies leben im paradies
schwärmt um durch die 48 jahre alte
barbara zweifelt so empfehlen studios es
ist sehr schön und ich bin sehr froh
dass ich die vermieter und wenn ich das
problem hat frau mit ihm besprechen
aber nein mir wenn jetzt nicht weiß wo
wir gesagt worden ist
rasta tochter wohl nicht sehen können
ist das lamento ihnen komme dass ein
erster schritt muss ich härter kultur
vergessen
also ich muss sie ältere kultur heute so
schön was ist wirklich sinnvoll und was
machen wir einfach wir schon immer
gemacht hat
ich bin so was ist nicht so dass man
mich aus so dass nun mit grafikchips
leistungen sie den soli sie abwechselnd
heißt es vom kaltes wasser lindert den
juckreiz
doch nicht alles lässt sich so einfach
beseitigen
zwischen den geschwistern kommt es immer
wieder zu spannungen
zu unterschiedlich ist ihre lebensweise
so auch jetzt als tom seine schwester
bittet ihn zum raster doktor zu
begleiten
das ziel im laufe der sohn ich werde mit
so habt ihr eine lauge sage ja meine
familie nicht alle wie ich unterschätze
nicht alles so wie ich bin ich schätze
so ist einfach denn ich komme ich das
schon gemacht
ich sage die macht
am nächsten tag auf dem weg zum raster
doktor ist barbara landolt nun doch mit
dabei sie ist es von berufs wegen
gewohnt auf menschen zuzugehen
sie arbeitet als cluster system ging an
einer heilpädagogischen schule haben wir
die entscheidung nicht einfach gemacht
ich habe nicht so gut geschlafen aber
wenn sie im leben und liebe gordon mache
ich das mit tom für die gemeinschaft ins
wartezimmer nur in diesem raum sind
filmaufnahmen erlaubt
ich hatte schon einige ratschläge habe
bin ich es auch in sachen wie gewohnt
vor zwölf eine größe ist auch wieder
probleme mit überhol und was heißt das
gespräch mit dem raster
so prägnant von der rastafari bewegung
ist das ist ja es ist für mich
interessante geschichte gesellschaft und
jamaika und raster war nichts frisches
kapital tosca reggae musik und ja also
das gehört dazu wie es zu der schweiz
wichtigste quelle der rastafari religion
ist die bibel im gegensatz zu den
christen glauben die rastas dass ihr
messias bereits wieder gekehrt ist
es handelt sich um den 1974 verstorbenen
kaiser haile selassie er war
staatsoberhaupt in äthiopien
und das ist eine ältere aufnahmen des
rasters bank heute ist der fast 90 jahre
alt und wohnt in diesem haus den
heutigen gästen zeigt er sich aber nicht
er schickt onboard davor dass so etwas
wie der mediensprecher des doktors ist
die hübsche dame
sie kann nicht mit ihr verwandt sein
schmeichelt bongo ort und hier haben wir
noch seine kleine schwester vom hat sich
extrem gut eingelebt in der
jamaikanische natur sagt tonko ort er
wird von uns allen akzeptiert als einer
von uns meiner meinung nach ist das
schon weit gekommen auf seiner
spirituellen reise die zu den weltweit
wichtigsten gehört die der rastafari
schade dass der außendruck kein
interview geben möchte gebe ich zum
ausdruck
es wäre schön mehr über ihn und seine
ideen in bezug auf natur zu erfahren
schauen sie nicht das hauptlos hand
sondern das halbvolle antwortet er
bleiben sie optimistisch optimistisch
aber weshalb zeigt sich der asta doktor
nicht will ich wissen
stellen sie die kamera ab schade dass
das gespräch in eine richtung gibt mit
der ich nicht umgehen kann
ich kann nicht bestimmen mit wem der
asta tochter spricht
der besuch endet ohne dass sich der asta
doktor gezeigt hätte
ich habe gespürt dass wirklich das
iranische system omen ist miss bild und
also dass sich jetzt einfach wie
bestätigt zugang wäre das für die
respektiere aber für mich dass du mich
schlagen und mir noch laufe
ich bin mit dem werber werke kultur und
religion sondern wirklich erklärt von
der person wo man hört nicht treffe
hängt mit der natur zwar gab das stimmt
aber nicht dass durch die recht die
religion des pakets mit behinderung und
mit tränen sie sagen mir dass du
[Musik]
ein paar tage später in einer ortschaft
am strand im westen jamaika tom hooper
und seine freundin danis moore sollen
eine woche ferien mit komfort verbringen
wieso haben sie das meter bessere
qualität nehmen also bis zu dem moment
bevor ich das weiße haus ist boxen schon
krass
was technisch aber ich denke er ist
speziell und heutigen speziellen thomas
mutter elisabeth hat die beiden
eingeladen
die 76 jahre alte frau wünscht sich dass
sich sohn und tochter näher kommen in
der gemeinsamen ferienwoche die beiden
beziehen eine suite mit eigener küche
und privat swimmingpool aber ich hatte
überlassen
begeistert ist das also es geht schon
rewards amerika muss die beste workflows
integriert
ja das ist ja das ist wie mallorca
haltet die baustelle müsse das nicht
leisten könnten antwortete das ist
schlecht christen musiker hatte und wo
gott so einfach nicht schaffen aus dem
buch
[Musik]
danke dass das sowieso 100
gegen ende der ferienwoche gibt es noch
eine besondere begegnung
thomas familie lernt jene von dani
scannen das ist hob nur die mutter von
denise wir geben sie nicht mehr her
sie ist so ein nettes mädchen und so gut
für meinen sohn und so endet diese
geschichte mit der erkenntnis braucht
toleranz um menschen einander näher zu
bringen
und manchmal eingeht
halle - ein wenig willen des stadtrates
[Musik]